was wäre wenn man ein terabyte
informationen auf einem fingernagel
unterbringen könnte oder noch besser ein
terabyte auf wenigen nanometern also
millionstel millimetern der absolute
wahnsinn skorpionen sollen das
ermöglichen das sind wirbel in
magnetischen materialien die tatsächlich
das zeug dazu haben unsere datenspeicher
und damit die computer zu
revolutionieren
das zeigen jetzt auch aktuelle
forschungsergebnisse aus halle
wie genau funktionieren skorpionen
welche unfassbaren vorteile sie haben
das jetzt im krieg zum science fiction
herzlich willkommen früher waren es
beispielsweise disketten oder usb sticks
auf denen man dateien videos und fotos
gespeichert hat heutzutage lädt man
einfach alles in einer cloud und kann
von überall auf der welt darauf
zugreifen letztendlich sind ja aber auch
hier die daten auf riesigen festplatte
abgespeichert und zwar meistens in
großen datencentern von unternehmen wie
google facebook apple und so weiter
technisch gesehen werden die einzelnen
daten bis durch einen mechanischen
schreib und lesekopf mit magnetfeld
pulsen auf eine schnell rotierende
scheibe also die festplatte geschrieben
das ist immer noch die gängige weil
preiswerteste methode doch diese
herkömmliche speichertechnik wird in
zukunft wohl an ihre grenzen stoßen denn
immer mehr daten sollen auf immer
weniger raum gespeichert werden und ein
erster schritt sind ja die ssds heiße
kandidaten für eine fortentwicklung das
sind diskussionen gemeint ist ein
spezielles magnetisches phänomen das
schon vor mehr als 25 jahren vom
physiker und physikerinnen theoretisch
vorhergesagt worden ist und vor einigen
jahren dann sind diese magnetischen
wirbel
die sich wie teilchen verhalten
experimentell in magnetischen
materialien nachgewiesen worden sie
haben viele eigenschaften die uns in
sachen moderner datenspeicherung extrem
nützlich sein könnten sie sind stabil
sie können sehr klein sein an
durchmesser von nur wenigen nanometern
und sie lassen sich durch geringe
elektrische ströme erzeugen und
manipulieren ein speicherchip auf scream
ionen basis könnte also deutlich energie
und platzsparender gebaut werden als
herkömmliche datenspeicher seite seinem
forschungsteam aus den usa im jahr 2015
zum ersten mal gelungen ist millionen
bei zimmertemperatur zu erzeugen und zu
manipulieren gelten sie als sehr sehr
viel versprechende zukunftstechnologie
ein forschungsteam aus halle hat jetzt
neue berechnung zu den kommunen
angestellt ihr ziel ist es
speichermedien robuster kleiner und bis
zu 1000 mal schneller zu machen
einer der beteiligten ist physiker
alexander schäffler zitat das besondere
an diesen quasi teilchen ist dass sie
sich in einem sehr stabilen topologische
geschützten zustand befinden und daher
eine geringe anfälligkeit gegenüber
externen einflüssen die temperaturen
oder erschütterungen aufweisen doch die
stabilität der skorpion ist auch ein
nachteil weiß das forschungsteam aus
halle
dadurch sind sie nur schwer zu erzeugen
und dann zudem noch schwer zu verändern
weil sich die sgo millionen aber wie
teilchen verhalten könnten die
speicherung von daten sehr viel
schneller passieren als wir es bislang
kennen und zwar innerhalb von
pikosekunden also dem billionstel einer
sekunde also in quasi nichts der
absolute wahnsinn das ist unfassbar viel
schneller als heute möglich komplett
neue anwendungen werden dadurch möglich
ich sage nur künstliche intelligenz im
binären code des computers könnten sie
für 10 stehen denn obwohl für millionen
sehr stabil sind könnten sie mit hilfe
von elektronenstrahlen ihre ausrichtung
verändern
sie entstehen spontan oder können in
schicht system erzeugt werden in denen
sich magnetische filme befinden
die wiederum die größe von etwa einem
nanometer haben wechselwirkung die sich
zwischen schwermetallen wie wolfram oder
platin und einem ferro magneten bilden
lasse millionen entstehen
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
weltweit denken über bauteile mit nano
plättchen nach auf denen vier millionen
angeordnet sind so müsste sich an dem
grundgerüst der geräte von heute
überhaupt nicht viel ändern ein
rotierender lese und schreib kopf könnte
dann die zustände der skorpion auslesen
oder auch ändern
den berechnungen aus halle zufolge
würden wohl rund sieben milliarden spam
millionen auf die fläche einer cent
münze passen umgerechnet entspricht das
etwa einem gigabyte an informationen und
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler hoffen sogar dass sie
den radius in zukunft auf einige
nanometer also ganz
verkleinern könnten das würde dann
bedeuten dass man acht millionen
skorpionen unterbringen könnte
umgerechnet also ein terabyte an
informationen und es gibt tatsächlich
hoffnung darauf dass diese
speichertechnologie in 15 bis 20 jahren
zum einsatz kommen könnte absolut irre
wenn er kein video zu diesem thema und
auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen
wollt dann würden wir hier ein abo aufs
auge und vergesst nicht den genau auf
die gore denn nur dann verpasst ihr kein
weiteres video tier hier geht es weiter
mit ihnen maß künstliche intelligenz die
größte gefahr für die menschheit da wird
einem schon ein wenig angst und bange
wenn es noch nicht gesehen habe dann
unbedingt anschauen oder ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran